well everybody welcome to another Python
mathematics and Finance tutorial video
this video we're gonna be talking about
the moving average envelope this one's
pretty simple and simple enough to where
I can condense it all into one video so
first let me just show you guys this
envelope it looks a lot like maybe these
Keltner channels or Bollinger Bands so
let's take a look at let's look at
Toyota so here they are for Toyota it's
the actually being plotted here right on
price and so the idea of these is to you
know encapsulate price and you can find
when there's been you know like a
breakout like for example we zoom in to
maybe this area here we can see where
price has broken out here and that's
obviously a very bullish indicator but
continues breaking out still bullish and
then finally here it breaks out now
we've got a bearish signal and again
bullish bowl as well as bearish right so
these are actually pretty simple what
you're doing is you're just taking a
simple moving average and then you're
multiplying that simple moving or adding
you know maybe a quarter or even like a
quarter of a quarter times that simple
moving average you've just Plus that and
minus that to get the direction right so
that also it will adjust itself by
volatility right so like here you can
see it's you know not too volatile as
far as you know comparison to here is
how much price it's been swinging around
by right so the gap is much smaller here
than it is here it gets much wider so so
will automatically adjust and it's just
like I said it's like really really
simple and you can see it really comes
down here it gets really thin there and
then it comes back up again but anyway
very simple because it's just a simple
moving average and then you add like a
multiple of that simple moving average
to the simple moving average and boom
you've got yourself some channels so
yeah so let's go ahead and get into the
actual programming of this to do that
let's go to syntax calm the sample code
is in there's a link for it in the
description that should take you to here
just come up to the script and copy and
paste everything
scrip and then go to an empty Python
script and paste it in so I'll bring it
over here let me just fit it to scream
[Music]
copy-paste
and normally if you have been following
along everything gets done right in here
but for this video we're not going to do
that because we want to plot it on that
on the price right not on that bottom
axes so we're going to come all the way
up to basically here and just hit enter
like a bunch make some space and then
we're going to go ahead and comment out
these two lines and because we've done
that the legend is going to like scream
at us so do a control F and in decibel
box type in legend and you'll find this
little block of code right here comment
it all out so it will go one two three
and one two three so now we don't have
to worry about those prices being shown
all that's going to come up now on that
middle axes is the candlestick next what
we want to do now is do this moving
average envelope so tab over a couple
times and we'll define env for envelope
and this is going to have two parameters
that we're gonna pass through prices and
a time frame so whatever envelope time
frame we want it's gonna have it's gonna
generate three lines right so we need an
upper line equals empty lower line
equals empty and then we want that
middle line and that'll be equal empty
as well for now then we're gonna be
using simple moving averages so I'm
gonna say SMAS equals moving average
whoops
prices time frame now moving average
we've already covered that in a previous
video so if you want to know more about
how calculated moving average check out
that video next get rid of that slide
next we want to say for each SMA in SMAS
what do we want to do well we're gonna
say upper lines so ul s equals each SMA
plus and then in here you can put
whatever value you want 0.05 seems to
work pretty decent so we'll say 0.05
times each SMA so as you can imagine
that just adds a little bit to the ESM
right and that'll kind of help us create
these like gaps right plus while it does
that it's also going to react to that
simple moving average depending on how
much how fast it's changing so that'll
make the gap either get wider or thinner
and which is also kind of an indication
of volatility change anyway next thing
we want to do is lower lines equals and
this is going to be the same thing only
a minus so I'm just going to copy and
paste this line and instead of adding
you're subtracting and then middle lines
is just equal to each SMA next we're
going to say upper line dot append upper
lines lower line dot append lines and
middle line up and little eyes finally
at the end once we've exhausted this for
loop what do we want to do we want to
return upper line lower line middle line
so that's that now what we want to do is
calm down Twitter cool so now what we
want to say is upper line lower Lyme
middle line equals env right EMP and
then prices time frame so we're gonna
use closed price and a time frame of ten
so now all we really need to do is a x1
dot plot and we want to do date - SP :
that's just our starting point if you
wanna know more about that check out the
charting stocks in python tutorial
series
they upper line
don't forget your - SP : oops - SP :
and in fact I'm just gonna copy and
paste X well in your mind we're gonna
copy and paste this whole function and
we want that line to be white now I'm
going to copy and paste this whole thing
paste that twice bam bam and now upper
line cool lower line and then middle
line and that's really it we should be
able to plot this now I believe
looks good let's do it here we go so
stock to Apple I'm trying of a stock we
haven't actually plotted yet it's like a
bajillion stocks and I just like you
never think of it recently let's do
let's do it big for Big Lots all right
so obviously the lower indicator is
empty because that was kind of like the
way we left it
so we could do other videos but this one
as we can see we definitely definitely
got it this one is obviously a pretty
volatile stock it's got a lot of
breaking out both on the top and the
bottom going on here quite the swinging
stock let me look at that that's pretty
interesting stock if you could time
those swings lots of money made there
anyway
so that's Big Lots as you can see that
it did indeed work out for us
I've got another one let's do Google and
again so here's Google fit it over here
a lot of breaking out for Google as well
so if you happen to if you don't want to
see like so much like cuz that's that's
really where the signal comes from is
where you have either a breakout on the
bottom or a breakout you know on the top
for bearish and bullish breaking out
right so if you don't that you can
change that obviously about coming over
to your formula and say you wanted to
see like you only wanted like a little
like a solid breakout and that was the
only thing you'd be interested in you it
would raise this number okay so let's
say 0.07 now now let's look at Google
again and see if we have just as many or
Big Lots probably another good one to
look at anyway you have a lot less
breaking out going on so if you wanted
to create like an algorithmic trading
system on this that said hey buy you
would get a lot less buy signals but
they'd probably be a little more solid
when it came to the buying signal itself
so like a good example of like the
trading system that people would build
off of this would be like right here
right so every time it breaks up out you
buy into it and then as soon as it comes
back in you would sell out of it and
then again you would have done the same
thing here bought in and then you'd sold
out
up here and you know you would have made
a decent amount of profit there the real
question is did you make more profit on
that time frame rather than just buying
in here and holding all the way till
today right and doing nothing so and
probably not you probably made more
money holding so anyway those are your
moving average envelopes pretty
interesting very basic and very easy to
implement into any basically any trading
system and also as far as like breakouts
are concerned and buying you know you
could just strictly calculate that upper
line and every time price exceeded that
upper line that would be a buy signal
right and then you would hold that until
price got back below that lower line
sell signal and you're good to go so
anyways that's going to conclude the
moving average envelope in fact that
kind of makes me want to save that idea
for later and maybe we'll will back test
the system of buying at you can use
machine learning to figure out the best
little line there or the best number to
multiply by anyway back test that idea
see how see if that actually works and
see if that does actually beat buying
and holding anyway ideas for the future
hopefully you guys enjoyed hopefully you
learned something new as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions until the next video